so let me tell you a little bit about
this project very much a work in
progress it's taking me a long time to
write it it's probably one of my most
ambitious books it is a cultural history
of Harlem kind of Harlem sits at the
base of it and you know from there the
city of New York during the 1940s
actually to be specific from about
nineteen thirty eight to nineteen forty
nine around the time of the passage of
the urban renewal act when things begin
to change significantly this is a period
that people have written about the
people have thought about for some time
what I hope is different about the
project that I'm engaged in is it's
looking at that history through the
lives and works of four women for women
artists and so basically you know I sort
of have four protagonist the reason why
I chose them their number of reasons
i'll talk about a little later but one
of the more specific reasons why i chose
them is that they all live in harlem
during this period all of them live in
harlem tell you a little bit about each
of them and Petry is the one I've been
working on the longest and the 1i with
whom I was most familiar initially
because I'm a literary scholar and she's
a novelist and she moved to Harlem in
1938 with her husband from Old Saybrook
Connecticut she was wrote about Harlem
wrote a number of short stories about
Harlem and a novel about Harlem but
that's not the only reason why I chose
her I chose her because she's really in
the thick of Harlem political and
cultural life during this period there
are a number of reasons why she works
for a newspaper called the People's
Voice if you all come across the
People's Voice yet People's Voice was a
newspaper founded by and published by
adam clayton powell right it was sort of
the journalistic wing of his activism it
was considered more
radical than any of the other Harlem
newspapers less sensationalist than the
Amsterdam news for instance and I'm
telling you how radical it was
considered that they used to call it
kind of The Daily Worker of Harlem right
he's like you know compare it to the
communist newspaper many of the people
who worked in the newsroom were
affiliated with the party and a number
of them would you know suffer under the
repression of the McCarthy era Petrie
I've not been able to place within the
party itself but she's surrounded by and
she is at that time she's a leftist she
surrounded by kind of the black left of
Harlem so she works for the People's
Voice she is the woman's editor she
basically covers society page right but
she also writes a number of articles
some of them sometimes and she writes a
number of editorials that are unsigned
the great thing about this is that she
knows Harlem from strivers Road a Sugar
Hill to the place where the poorest
southern migrants are moving in she
walks that beat she had been a reporter
and then she becomes an editor you kind
of follow her through the 1940s and you
get a real sense of the sort of texture
of the city she is engaged in a number
of civic and political activities
through the People's Voice some of the
things that she has also organized
herself including an organization called
Negro Women incorporated which later she
would say was a consumer advocacy
organization right but really it was an
organization an attempt to organize
black women around the issues that most
affected them particularly economic
issues she also was involved in the
American Negro theater kind of the
foundation of radical Black Theatre
found it in the 1940s so there she was
associating with people who were
politically engaged actors Harry
Belafonte Sidney Poitier Lloyd Richards
who would later go on to
to be the Broadway director of all of
august wilson's plays he's there too
it's kind of a not just a hotbed of
political activity but it's also this
place that's going to nurture young
artists who would become major stars by
the 50s Ruby Dee and Ossie Davis are
there right and so Petrie is right in
the middle of that she is significant to
me in this project because because I
want to keep Harlem kind of as the
center of it Petrie is the one who stays
mostly in Harlem I mean as far as I can
trace her as far that she gets she
doesn't even leave she comes to the like
very tip by coming to columbia for
classes right so columbia for her is
just another harlem institution right
she takes classes in creative writing
but to really get a feel for just what
every day life is like following Petrie
is a great way to do it she writes a
short story called in darkness and
confusion and in darkness and confusion
is a story about a all of her stories at
this time are about working class people
most of whom are migrants she is always
writing stories and her most famous
novel the street about a Harlem that's
just about to explode this is before
Langston Hughes his famous poem or does
it explode right so she writes a short
story it's about a family but she allows
us to I have specific people who we can
walk the streets of Harlem with right at
the beginning of August 1943 and one of
her characters is in a hotel that's very
much like the Braddock and the story
ends up about being part of the crowd
during the Harlem riot of 43 so that's
Petrie she's one of the people who take
us through Harlem the second person is
pearl primas who is Trinidadian born
dancer choreographer not as famous today
as katherine dunham though she should be
always always connected related her art
to her political activism in
fact I opened up with her attending one
of the Negro freedom rallies at Madison
Square Garden in 1943 she would be at
most of the political rallies providing
a source of entertainment she was
probably the one of the major artists to
bring African dance to the American
stage so she already has a kind of
internationalist perspective she's a pan
africanist early on and very much
engaged in seeing no separation between
her politics in her art the third person
is Mary Lou Williams composer pianist
brilliant brilliant self-taught musician
who moves to Harlem in the early forties
actually she moves in 43 and her
introduction into the real you know the
relationship between Harlem artists and
Harlem politics is she performs at a
rally for benjamin davis who would
become Harlem's councilman communist
party member right councilman and so
she's one of the many performers who
would perform there and she becomes of
the four women she's the one who
maintains a home in Harlem until the day
she dies and a fourth woman takes us to
a different part so we kind of have this
sort of mapping going on here we have
Petrie who's basically situated in
Harlem and gives us a real sense of what
that place is like in the 1940s we have
a premise who's moving in and out of
kind of left-wing dance circles
especially the new dance group which is
a group that believes that dance should
have some relationship to the social and
political and also be about trying to
make social change so she's moving in
and out of that we have Mary Lou
Williams who is in Harlem and spends her
night down in the village at Cafe
Society right she's the house pianist
basically they're at Cafe Society so
while she's not doing a lot in the
beginning in terms of her politics in
Harlem if you know anything about cafes
I a cafe society is where lengths to use
would come up with Paul ropes and on his
arm and adam clayton powell would be
sitting there but he enjoyed the he
enjoyed the intellectual conversation
but he was also falling in love with a
young pianist named hazel scott who he
would marry at some point so all of this
is going on Mary Lou Williams is there
and she really becomes politicized in
that context right so she takes us from
Harlem she shows us the connections
between Harlem and the village my final
person is a truly fascinating woman
there's a new documentary out about her
if you get a chance to see it her name
is Alice Neel and she is the only one of
the three women who is not
african-american she is a white woman
she is the only one of the three women
who was definitely without question a
member of the Communist Party when she
becomes pregnant with a for a Latino man
in the late late 30s she has to move to
harlem because we have to remember New
York is still New York is you know it's
up north but it's a Jim Crow town right
and there aren't many places where
african-americans can live or even
patronize so once she becomes pregnant
with this color baby she's got to move
uptown she moves to East Harlem which is
not yet el barrio but it will become a
barrio and she and her paintings through
her paintings documents not grand
figures but she documents the immigrants
who are coming in from Puerto Rico right
and she documents them in such a way to
show their nationals you no sense of
national identity but also they're at
their racial diversity right and she
mostly paints women and families but
that's not all she paints tuberculosis
victims and she is also the only one of
the three women who is not acquiring a
degree of Fame at this time and I'll
talk a little bit about why the 40s
become so important for these women to
become famous but she
is not she's kind of laying low or i
should say laid low because the artistic
community in New York won't recognize
her right they won't recognize her she
one of the reasons why and I think this
is why I love her so much she continues
to paint figure she paints people she
cares about people this is a period when
we start to get the emergence of
abstract expressionism she never goes
there to her it's politically bankrupt
she's not going to do that and she says
you know when they talk about her not
painting abstraction she says will turn
the painting upside down it's abstract
if you do that right so she's
fascinating fascinating woman she will
raise two sons as a single mother in
Spanish Harlem she's also the only one
who I know for a fact was visited by the
FBI when we get the rise of McCarthyism
right Petrie leaves town when all of her
friends start getting called before
McCarthy so I don't know what happens to
her premise there's some suggestion that
she's under surveillance right but Neil
actually does get visited by the FBI so
those are the UM women you step back a
little bit and talk about a little about
method 1 i'm very much interested in
Harlem as a space that is where there is
always a contestation over what it will
be who it will belong to and what it
will mean right what will Harlem mean
and that that contest is going on
between mainstream media that's trying
to represent it in one way and the black
media that's trying to represent it in
another way right it will go on between
black people themselves in Harlem right
it'll go on between the nationalist and
the left is although those aren't really
strictly defined lines in every case
someone like Queen Mother oddly more who
will become well Queen Mother of black
nationalist movement is the campaign
director for benjamin davis right so the
lines are can be fluid sometimes right
so that's another kind of point of
contestation Harlem is a space where let
early the space itself is being fought
over but also what it means right what
it means to the world what it means to
the country it already has a sense of
itself as the kind of global capital of
the black world right it's had that for
a while by the time the period i'm
talking about its had that for about 20
years now an important thing is the
distinction between this period and the
period that is most well known and
that's of course the Harlem Renaissance
period this period is different for a
number number of reasons with as with
black America in general in the 1940s
there's this feeling that there's
something new under a foot right there
is the double V campaign right where
will be patriotic will fight but we're
not going to give up our fight for civil
rights here you know we're not going to
be accused of being unpatriotic here so
there's a double V campaign there's a
sense of movement and mobility is more
and more migrants become parts of cities
it's the time of the Second Great
Migration which is very different in
character from the first great migration
the artistic movement is also very
different even though you'll still have
some figures from the earlier period who
join this period as well most most
notably Langston Hughes right Lex
accuses star of the Harlem Renaissance
and he's becomes a kind of Dean of
African American letters during this
time so he's still there but it's
different in that in that the artists
are very self-conscious about defining
themselves over and against the image of
them in the 1920s right they are not as
accepting of white patronage they saw
white patronage as being one of the
things that stifled the movement in the
20s they are much more explicitly
political they connect their work not
just and this is what this is important
I don't want you to think of the arts as
kind of a reflection of society
they see their artwork is really shaping
society helping to influence society
right it's a way of practicing their
politics right so there's no distinction
for them between kind of a formal
formalism and a politically engaged art
so in that way it's different as well
it's especially different for the women
that I'm interested in because I don't
think ever before do we have sort of
mainstream the kind of mainstream
cultural apparatus opening up in ways
that it does to women at this period it
just the 1920s didn't do it p trees
books are reviewed in The Times pearl
premise is the darling of the New York
Times dance critic Mary Lou Williams
gets reviewed widely again I told you
Alice Neel doesn't which said something
about them but also said something about
the time period as well so one of the
things where Mary beard and the artist
said about this period he was coming of
age during this time he says the
movement was a positive and
participatory realization of what it
meant to be black not on the soire
scale of the Harlem Renaissance but on a
mass scale the dig at the Harlem
Renaissance which wasn't always on the
soire scale so other things about this
period that contribute to the conditions
that will you know give rise to these
women won the war of course right
because the war does a number of things
it helps to create more opportunities
for women because men are away right but
it also does something to African
American consciousness african-american
political consciousness the membership
of the n-double-a-cp shifts through the
roof largely because of what happens to
black soldiers right black soldiers
dressed in their uniforms you know come
and get lynched in the United States or
the treatment of black soldiers in base
camps in the south right but the
membership of the n-double-a-cp shoots
through the roof the war also provides
better economic opportunity provides
jobs and we also see these women
beginning to join unions
right not not women not the artist I'm
talking about but kind of the migrant
women who are able to move in to move
out of domestic service and into very
kind of low-skilled war industry jobs so
the war is also very significant I
mentioned the WWE campaign the other
thing that's significant is the Popular
Front ok so the Popular Front was
nurtured by a number of organizations
that would nurture the talents of these
women the Popular Front is most often
associated with the 1940s but historians
of black American literature and culture
and you know social history say that the
Popular Front actually extended in black
life longer from longer than it did in
general on the general left as early as
februari 1936 we get a coalition of
black groups meeting in Chicago as the
National Negro Congress to Val quote
support for black culture and cultural
workers particularly in the fight
against demeaning stereotypical images
in the public arts right so that's the
Popular Front all of these women are
involved in some popular front
organization People's Voice Cafe Society
new dance group there they're all
engaged so those organizations are
actually helping to educate them
politically providing nurturance for
their art and patronage for their art
form right helping them find and
identify audiences and also educating
them and giving them a sense of
themselves as something you know as
being very much identified with a black
struggle very much identified with
Harlem but also of that simply being
part of a larger not just nationwide
movement of progressive people but
worldwide movement of progressive people
of which Harlem is going to be central
so those are the things that are most
significant rush to this because I don't
want to take up too much time about them
I want to focus on just briefly on one
of the women because I thought maybe
that might
interesting to know about her and
because she also gives us a her
experiences give us a real sense of the
time so Mary Lee Williams as I said Mary
the waves was a child prodigy started
playing the piano by ear when she's
about three years old never was formally
trained was from Pittsburgh went on the
road for a long time as the main
arranger for the Andy Kirk Orchestra she
also you never hear this she also
arranged for Duke Ellington Duke
Ellington only had two really important
arrangers Billy Strayhorn and Mary the
wing thing although i don't use the word
often because i think it's thrown around
too much but i think it's okay to say
that she was a genius it's okay to say
that she is on the road throughout most
of her career but in 43 she comes to
Harlem she settles isn't settled in
hamilton terrace alright have any of you
been to st. Nick's pub or near those
plays it's right near there that's where
she settled she gets an apartment there
and she has this gig down at Cafe
Society her apartment will become the
sort of home space to some too Minton's
club as a kind of public space so
Minton's of course is legendary for
being the home where bud powell and
Thelonious Monk and Dizzy Gillespie and
Charlie Parker would invent beba a new
vocab vocabulary for jazz what does
isn't as legendary is it Mary Lou's
apartment they were there too all right
she had a piano she left the door open
she gave them keys she they worked out a
lot of stuff there and recognized her as
a kind of godmother to that music
Thelonious Monk would come and wake her
up and say listen to this and so she's
also a kind of tutor there so she's
engaged in the most important kind of
cultural movement happening in Harlem at
the time she's playing at Cafe Society
you know she has like a nine o'clock
show and 1100 I think it's like a seven
o'clock show nine o'clock show midnight
show as soon as she's done she's in a
taxi she hurries up to Harlem she goes
to mittens
she goes to 50 second Street she's there
and then she's at home right where her
door is always open for these musicians
so that's basically her life in terms of
her political engagement it largely
comes through Cafe Society because
Barney josephson is the owner of cafe
society he encourages his artists to be
politically involved that's why why
Billy Holladay will sing strange fruit
because of Barney josephson so he'll
send them up to a rally or send them to
a meeting or say that they're available
for any number of things she's slowly
becoming aware about Harlem during this
period because of that now in the after
the war is over music begins to change
bebop has moved from Harlem to 50 second
street and Harlem begins to change she
takes some time off from work to really
get to know her neighborhood and she
watches as everybody and their mother
leaves Harlem all the middle class to go
to where do they go any idea where they
moved to most of them Queens they all
move to queens right they go to corona
Billie Holiday moves to Queens Dizzy
Gillespie moves to Queens Louis
Armstrong moves the Queen's I think
Dinah Washington move degrees they all
move right the war opens up certain
housing opportunities the war doesn't
just do it struggle does it right but
housing opportunity things work up so
the black middle class is starting to
desert Harlem right we get the passage
of the urban renewal Act where we get
clubs that have been central and
mainstays of a black community life
closing down and we get the rise for the
first time of a discourse about
delinquents juvenile delinquents gangs
gang war all the things you would expect
when resources and communities Lucius's
move out in communities break up and she
becomes involved in trying to
acknowledge and work with young people
it becomes it will become central to her
for the rest
her life and her decision to stay in
Harlem and to continue to write her
music there even even if she leaves she
goes to Paris she goes to Europe she
keeps that apartment it's a very
conscious political decision that tucci
believes that to transform a community
to change a community you have to live
in that community you have to be there
right and so that's what she decides to
do I'll stop there you have a sense of
what this project is all about if you
take nothing else away take away the
project's desire to break down very
strict boundaries between what
constitutes the political the social and
the artistic right in the creek or two
to act as if there are activists in
their artists right that this kind of
collapses some boundaries there so I'll
stop and open it up for questions or
comments or anything else that you might
have yeah did I do it in time yeah okay
yeah so any any questions anything I did
give the right talk though nothing
yes
I'm not I mean I think it did even the
art there was an explicitly political
did you know the art that claim to be
art for art's sake had an embedded
political message I think for the artist
that I'm talking about without
questioning it did like the least
politicized of them was Mary Lou
Williams and one of the reasons why I
chose her was that I said I find it very
interesting that she's the one who
doesn't have the framework the analysis
right she just has like a genuine
commitment to her community right and
that's what makes her become actively
engaged but for all of these artists at
this time there are they actually this
is interesting they don't see a
distinction between being able to
produce high quality art and art that is
also politically engaged right for them
there isn't a distinction so they're not
out there producing flat-footed art
right they're producing complex artworks
bebop you know is there there's nothing
more complex than bebop at this moment
right i mean it's engaging all kinds of
harmonic structures it's but though all
of those bebop artists were
self-consciously saw their art is being
political even even as it was abstract
so yeah hmm yes
right right I think the reason why this
period is so interesting is that you
know Harlem is this mean Harlem is
Harlem the Harlem that the world knows
because black people were there right
now they weren't always there you've
learned that I'm sure right they weren't
always there they came and ever since
there came there's been a slow process
of changing that community the 40s is so
interesting I think because in that
period you can see that change begin to
happen I mean it gives us a long view of
history so what you can begin to see
what I mean is the groundwork that's
kind of put down especially after the
war especially with the passage of the
urban renewal act is groundwork that
will allow for the Harlem that we know
as a kind of wasteland as a
representative a kind of wasteland and
abandoned houses and a drug scourge that
that happens in the 40s what happens in
the late 40s allows that to happen and
when that happens it creates the perfect
conditions for people to come in and
develop it right to say that they're
developing it right so that's one thing
I'd say is just this kind of long view
of history that gentrification doesn't
just start happening when the
brownstones start selling for millions
and millions of dollars and some of
these women particularly Petrie can kind
of see it already early on when she sees
what's beginning to happen right that's
one thing the other thing I think is um
getting old my thought just went out of
my head lessons to be learned long view
of history it'll come back to me but
that I mean I think that is probably
what we learn from this period most is
that we see Harlem as this vibrant
vibrant place still kind of having a
sense of itself as a cultural capital
from the Harlem Renaissance still coming
out of the 30s where it has become a
radicalized community right through the
depression right so radicalized that it
will easily elect communists to City
Council right this real heightened sense
of hope and possibility and hope that's
generated by social movement right it's
generated by people by social movement
and yet at the same time sort of the
forces that come in to begin to
transform that some of those forces
seeming like opportunities right
opportunities so that the middle class
can sleep right and go pursue the dream
of great integration I think they also
the other thing about the lessons that I
think we can learn is that the notion
that social movements don't just pop out
of nowhere like Topsy you know if you've
read Uncle Tom's Cabin II know she's
like I had no mother had no father I
just is right that they because
everything that we see that will emerge
later on in the 1960s are strategies
that we see starting in the 1940s it's
important to remember Ella Baker is
living in Harlem at this time Pauli
Murray is living in Harlem at this time
20 the other thing I was going to say is
that the other lesson to learn is to is
that people are always engaged and
struggle about their communities always
and maybe not where you expect to see it
the most I think that's another reason
why Petrie is interesting because we
know what Adam Clayton Powell is doing
right but we don't know what kind of the
average everyday working class woman is
doing what is she doing to try to
address the concerns of her community so
that you know there's always it's like
Gramsci says right there's there's a
kind of a dominant move but there's
always something underneath of it that's
still going on so I think those are the
two lessons learned yes
I think that that's what Mary Lou
Williams believed right right right
Williams I think I mean I was talking
about specific moments in her history
one when she chooses to stay she doesn't
own that apartment she's paying rent the
whole time right when she chooses to
stay after everyone else leaves she
thinks initially that she's going to
Europe for two weeks and unscrupulous
producers kind of pull the rug out from
under her feet and then she she
undergoes a kind of emotional breakdown
while she's there so she ends up staying
much longer than she planned she goes to
a religious conversion I'm which even
makes her even more interestingly like
committed in a way and when she returned
she returns to that apartment in Harlem
she I mean some things she does you know
you could say are crazy no she tries to
run a rehab center in her apartment
because so many musicians are on drugs
right so many moons so she brings them
to her apartment feeds them hasn't go
cold turkey in her apartment she will
open up a thrift store that tries to fun
you know projects that she's interesting
in particularly projects for young
people so I don't think that she is one
of those people who moves out but
maintains this physical space without
being there when she's there she's there
she's you know she is engaged in that
way because I think that she would say
exactly what you're saying like how do
you maintain a sense of engagement if
you don't even know and I this is
interesting I didn't say this about her
what really changes her you know it
makes her begin to believe that is that
she had been living in Harlem for about
three or four years she was sleeping in
Harlem basically right and then she was
or maybe she'd go to the clubs at night
but she was mostly down in the village
she needs a break she's been performing
she's exhausted she needs a break so she
takes a break and instead of going away
from her break she stays in Harlem and
she walks the streets of Harlem and she
realizes oh my god I don't even know
this place I didn't know this community
and she walks it at night versus walking
in the day cuz Harlem is a different
place at night than it is during the day
and she gets to see it at night and it's
not always pretty and then one of her
neighbors gets killed in a gang war
right and so I think that that notion of
you have to be there to be engaged as
because it's almost a self critical
notion I was here all this time and I
didn't even know what was happening in
my own community so I hope that answers
your question yes ok um blurt two at a
time yet
okay all right so let me do those two
first okay the religion I would say that
my women my women are always spiritual
people none of them at the time that I'm
writing about them are engaged in
organized religion none of them and I
think there's a reason why for each of
them alice neel is a Marxist all right
so she's got a critique of organized
religion pearl primas while it's not a
kind of self-described Marxist is a
leftist and is discovering at this point
this is before she goes to africa she
goes to africa in 1949 but she's
beginning to discover elements of black
spirituality that are not Christian
right african spirituality base although
she doesn't interesting enough she goes
south and she in order to learn a kind
of vocabulary a body vocabulary of
movement to incorporate in her dance she
lives with sharecroppers and watches
their movement in church especially kind
of the aesthetic move but she's not
worshipping in those churches and ptree
if i'm not mistaken had been a Catholic
I'm her husband certainly was a Catholic
and before he's deployed overseas he's
in Washington he goes into a Catholic
Church and priest says to him this is a
white church you can't pray here so he
never steps foot in another Catholic
Church Mary Lou Williams is I would say
at this point a seeker she's a seeker
right but she's not interesting enough
she's not going to church and I think
partly that's because she's a jazz
musician she's in the middle of what
many people consider an extremely
decadent life right now the conversion
that she undergoes interestingly enough
is um she becomes Catholic
she doesn't become Baptists or
Pentecostal she becomes Catholic and
it's because while she's in Europe and
she's undergoing this kind of emotional
difficulty its priests to reach out to
her so she becomes Catholic and she
comes back and she writes a number of
masses around black st. the black st.
Martin de Porres and things like that
her religious conviction would
definitely inform what she does later on
the other thing I think why Catholicism
I don't think there are a number of
reasons why Catholicism was attractive
to her and we can talk about that later
but seeking interestingly enough the
black church was not going to accept her
music right at that time the black
church you know was not going to accept
jazz the Catholic Church well they
weren't really that excited about
something black people anyway they
didn't care whether you were seeing
gospel or jazz right so she could write
these masses that were really jazz
masses in the catholic church the
Catholic Church welcomed her in that way
so those are the answers to those two
questions now what were the others
yeah okay all right okay yeah okay all
right so um I'll answer that when I was
to the first one first communism is
appealing to black people during this
period especially during the 30s because
unlike it's the only political party
that makes the concerns of
african-americans central right the only
one and I think that sometimes it's you
know a full-fledged commitment sometimes
it's a kind of dance and interesting
dance what can you do for me what can I
do for you right but I think that's what
it is that you know they are organizing
people in Harlem it against evictions
the Democrats aren't doing that the
Republicans aren't doing that so I think
that in general you have many black
people even if they don't become
communists open to people who are
helping them right and also it's not
just in New York I mean Robin Kelly's
book hammer and ho looks at it in
Alabama and how black people aren't
pawns of the Communist Party they
actually transform right so I think
that's one of the reasons the artists
and the intellectual or the artists in
particular in this this group of artists
I would say it's because one they they
are primarily concerned with issues of
poor and working class black people with
the exception of ptree they mostly come
from the working class well Neal doesn't
neal comes from an elite class and they
also are they have their own kind of
cultural heroes who basically model for
them how to be an artist and the two
people for all of them the black women
who model for them how to be an artist
the two people they adore Langston
Hughes and Paul Robeson they worship at
the feet of Paul Robeson all right so
they have a certain set of model
of what it means to be a politically
engaged artists and finally the
Communist Party has it and not
necessarily the party itself but is
affiliated with cultural institutions
and cultural organs that will support
their art right Richard right when he
wants to become a writer no one's taking
him that seriously especially about the
issues that he's writing about he
allowed to become a writer he gets a
critical audience he gets some people
who will help him read through the John
Reed clubs of the Communist Party right
and so I think all of those are reasons
why now the UM my background in English
and complet is so bogus it's just like I
mean I love literature I love the arts I
don't have an English degree anywhere in
my background at all my undergraduate
degree is in history and literature my
graduate degree is in American Studies
I've always been introduced Oakland area
to the core Columbia's English
department just happened to say well she
liked the way she does literature i
guess but mostly they didn't even have
anything to do with it Manning brought
me here through african-american studies
so you know I mean I happen to be housed
in English departments and you know I
can I teach literature but so I there I
said it I said it it's bogus it is
utterly impossible for me to do that
task like I did a thing for NPR is it do
any of you listen to news and notes in
PR ed gordon used to have the show they
asked me to they had sole series on
reading and writing and they asked me to
do a series where i selected the six
most influential order if they said six
most influential or important books by
or writers writers that's what they
asked me to do how do i do that right
six I mean that's so first I did stuff
like I said um well I'm only going to
have one from before the 20th century
and out so it's not that the other ones
aren't important but actually that's not
true of 14 set one for the 18th century
14 the 19th century and the rest are
going to be 20th I'm only going to have
one poet writes I had to go through all
those artificial things right
all right so who did I give him and I
wouldn't give you the same ones to
answer your question but because she
wanted three phillis wheatley because
she's first and because I think she
deserves reconsideration because
everybody reads that poem that she wrote
about oh you bought me from pagan Africa
I'm so grateful you made me a Christian
blah blah blah she was 14 when she wrote
that you know she has another poem to
the Earl of Dartmouth who's coming over
to oversee the colonies and she talks
about I'm so glad you're coming she's
all caught up in this revolutionary
fervor America weights you you know
America wants her freedom blah blah blah
blah blah and then hidden in like the
third stanza she says you probably
wonder how someone like me has so much
to say about freedom and then she goes
on to say you know I am the epitome of
the people who desire or freedom right
you know she taught so I think she
deserves a reconsideration right so
Peter so she was one the second one and
I chose was Frederick Douglass and I
still believe whatever list i picked
Frederick Douglass would be it if you
couldn't read anything else 1845
narrative I mean it transforms American
literature it transforms
african-american literature the slave
narrative slave narrative can never be
the same after that because suddenly
it's not just about the escape from
slavery to freedom it's about the kind
of psychological interior life of the
slave whose brilliant right so 1845 and
then what did I select now after this he
gets murky I'm starting not to remember
I think I selected um hmm that's
interesting Richard right I did Richard
right because he is the first black
writer who can make money as a writer
can make his living as a writer because
there's has no novel before or since
that made such a splash as did native
son whatever you think about that novel
it really did create important national
dialogue and also for some of his other
writings but I think and he also was so
influential on the following generation
so native son would be one of them then
I'm trying to think who I picked after
that James Baldwin and I would say more
so than the novels I would read the fire
next time and then an early essay called
Harlem I think where he writes about it
he writes about Harlem what Harlem is
like in the 1940s but he writes about
riding through the streets of Harlem to
the on his way to the cemetery his
family to bury his father but the
streets they're riding through it's the
morning after the riots of 1943 then I
picked how many is that for oh wow so
who was number 50 Zora Neale Hurston I
picked Hurston not because of her impact
during the time when she was published
but because of her impact later on and
because I think their eyes were watching
god is one of the most beautiful novels
ever written and then Morrison Morrison
yeah because she occupies a space as a
cultural leader figure thinker public
intellectual that I can't think of
another black writer who occupy that
national internationally so those are my
six you can pick three out of the hook
okay anything else any other questions
yeah there's one back here yeah mm-hmm
mmm good question two of them were
friends Mary Lou Williams and pro
previous were good friends because they
both worked at Cafe Society and Mary Lou
Williams pro premiums would dance to
Mary Lou's music all the time and very
Lou actually dedicates a song to her she
does a famous zodiac sweet and she's the
first black woman to have her sweet
played at both town hall and Carnegie
Hall and one of these signs I don't
remember which one maybe it's Libra is
dedicated to Pearl primas that's the
only personal connection between the two
of them Petrie new of all new of the
three because she's writing about them
Alice Neel is living in east harlem
right and she is you know nobody she is
a dedicated devoted artist to her own
detriment and the detriment of her
children sometimes but for the most part
she is accepted in that community I mean
she she is an important member of the
community she and I am one of the ways I
mean people talk about her but one of
the ways you can tell also is that
people willingly sit for her she paints
I mean she just paints these incredible
portraits I'll see if I can pass one of
them around quickly they willingly sit
for her she's just kind of this quirky
white woman who who paints them and I
think that if I don't know I know a very
few black neighborhoods that don't have
at least one resident who is white right
now the opposite isn't always true but
Alice neo would have been that person in
Spanish Harlem so let me see if i can
find that no i didn't print it out
unfortunately i'll make sure um
professor marable gets it just so you
can see what she does with her community
she document basically she documents
this way I like to think of her
documents an emerging community before
the social scientists and the media
discover it that's what she does yeah
okay thank oh yes nori hi nori
a protest against it or yeah okay the
first question the Queen's I don't know
who lives me I don't know about a black
artistic community in Queens right now I
but that doesn't mean doesn't exist I
just don't know about it and I should
say those people who moved it's not like
the way people move like you know aaron
douglas the painter used to read crisis
magazine and he's in Kansas and he knew
that Harlem was where he should be
because Langston Hughes was there and
Dubois was there so he came there it's
not that movement to queens in the 40s
and 50s is not the same thing so
basically it's a movement of the black
middle class and these are the musicians
who have made it into their they're the
elite of that and so they're moving as a
kind of class moves now it's important
to Billie Holiday that Armstrong lives
around the corner yeah but what I think
of it this is how I think of it I think
of it like there are a lot of black jazz
musicians now who live not just black
but a lot of jazz musicians who live in
Montclair New Jersey I don't think they
went there to start a cultural movement
right they went there because who can
afford to live in New York because it's
the most integrated town it's a nice
town and it happens to be a hip town
because they're there and they play
right so I think that that's what the
Queen's move was more like it wasn't
like people moving to follow Spike Lee
like my classmates you know in brooklyn
in the 80s or anything the other
question that's a harder question for me
to answer I mean I I can't answer that
as an expert I think that um is there a
silencing I think that you know there's
certain things that just don't get
coverage right I mean what
what gets coverage is the new Harlem
Renaissance right Harley I see a ton of
those kinds of articles the new Harlem
Renaissance there's a Italian bakery
just opened you know and now we're
starting to see things like Copeland's
closing or in the new york times or the
brother who for years sold the record
store right that closing we're starting
to see that but even that isn't done in
a very critical way it's done in a kind
of nostalgic where the passing of the
old guard way when I have gone to anti
gentrification protests and I haven't
gone recently because I've been away but
when I have gone to them I have seen no
evidence of you know the mainstream
media there at all really I mean I see
evidence of you know so in that way
there might be a silencing the other
thing I think is that this is just a
very complicated thing that's happening
you know because it's not only the new
Harlem i'ts are not only defined by
their race all right I'm so it's just a
very complicated thing that's happening
so that i don't know that everything is
a result of a kind of conscious
silencing of protests although i do
believe that exists and here's another I
just heard recently about a meeting
where a lot of people who represented
themselves as workers came into a
meeting a kind of pro not pro
gentrification but kind of pro
development meeting but that's not who
they were right so in that way it gives
the appearance of a kind of balanced
view of people on both sides when in
fact that might not have really been the
case and so that's a different kind of
silencing okay thank you